so um what's the deal with trust I'm not
talking about trusting yourself I trust
myself I'm not talking about trusting
your friends I trust my friends right I
know they'd put their lives on the line
for me or at least I like to think so
enough to function as if that's the case
I'm talking about trust in a romantic
context right I'm talking about opening
your heart to someone and say Here I am
do you love me I'm talking about the
kind of trust that we say is putting it
all out there right the trust that asks
for nothing less than everything
[Music]
Wow see see that means that means
risking it all right
that means risking absolute rejection
that means submitting to potentially the
involuntary killing of the ego which is
different than submitting to the
voluntary killing of the ego see this is
not you saying I'm taking ayahuasca and
I'm risking it all including all the
frameworks of reality that governed my
life up to this point no no no that's a
voluntary submission when we fall in
love we submit to the involuntary
possibility of betrayal of somebody
saying hey you trusted me and I'm gonna
trample all over that which means your
sense of certainty your sense of faith
the part of you that felt safe in that
relationship that knowing that you trust
on that knowing that keeps you grounded
right the place where you plant your
feet
it's called into question right romantic
betrayal right calls your assumptions
about somebody you thought you knew into
question your trust being betrayed in
love calls all certainty it's a question
if all your assumptions about this
beloved are called into questions then
all your assumptions about the world are
called into question and all of a sudden
my friend you are thrust into chaos into
the underworld right into the water of
this organization and disorder
underneath the frozen lake on which we
all walk this is the snake and it sneaks
into our garden
[Music]
I know for myself towing this line
between chaos and order has meant a
predisposition towards negative emotion
an impulse to control everything I can
control to steward the contents of my
experience to exercise agency at every
moment that is the reason why surrender
is often the most difficult thing and
why I only do it when I feel like I am
safe
I practice instead a form of disciplined
surrender a kind of flow right that is
in between discipline and chaos I'm in
calculated surrender I'm in safe
resignation
how does that affect my romantic life
well it makes me absolutely terrified
every time I fall in love it makes me
experience a kind of neediness that is
disorienting and destabilizing because I
realize in that moment Wow I could go
there
I could lose my [ __ ] for someone
[Music]
the possibility of romantic rejection
when one has opened their heart is Wow
[Music]
is to be denied so completely in that
moment that is akin to a kind of death a
death of innocence a broken heart
and perhaps upon picking up the pieces
[Music]
The Commitments never to let that happen
to me again that we all go bankrupt by
the age of three
at the end of the film call me by your
name the central father figure tells his
son who has just been ravished by love
and loss
to make ourselves feel nothing
so is not feel anything what a waste
so with the Hertz breathe through it
do not go quietly into that good night
rage against the line to die of the
light and trust again and trust again